want a glimpse of where all this is
going look no further than our neighbor
to the north
now you may have seen this video of the
canadian pastor
kicking the coveted mask enforcers out
of his church
well just days ago the authorities
caught up to him
after he held a morning church service
and then
watch what happened
that man pastor artur pavlovsky joins me
now pastor
you said you spent 30 hours in solitary
confinement
after what we just saw yeah
we we have no no rights whatsoever the
what we have right now is some kind of a
hybrid between the fascism and communism
medical tyranny it looks like we have
absolutely no
rights whatsoever the the premiere of
alberta right now declared the
protesting is illegal so when i opened
my church
in the protest against the government
overreach
i was as you saw i was uh taken to
custody
i was a manhandled
they really really wanted me to be hurt
they threw me into a cell they deprived
me from
sleep for two days i spent three days in
jail
for my crime of opening the church in a
free and democratic society
did you ever think you would see this in
a supposedly free and democrat society
a former eastern bloc you know you know
what tyranny and
dictatorships are like did you ever
think you would see this
no i escaped tyranny i escaped communism
and socialism i came to canada only
because canada was offering me freedom
and here we are again a repetition of
history and i decided i'm going to stand
up and fight to the dead that's what i
said to the officer
you know you're not going to intimidate
me you can torture me if you want to
shoot me dead or taser me
but i'm going to fight until the day i
die i have three children
and if you know that's my message to the
people if you don't want to do it for
yourself
please have some decency and do it for
your children because what kind of
country
are we going to leave behind for the
future generation
how are we going to look into the faces
of our children our sons and daughters
and say to them yeah we allowed this to
happen we did nothing
we didn't care about your future
here's what the police said about your
arrest law enforcement recognizes
people's right to
desire to participate in faith-based
gatherings as well as right to protest
however as we find ourselves in the
midst of a global pandemic we all must
comply with
public health orders pastor your
reaction
oh it's it's a sham this whole thing is
a big fat lie
when i grew up behind the iron curtain
that's what we were receiving on a daily
basis lie
manipulation misinformation if you were
looking for the truth you were arrested
sentenced to jail if you were caught
listening to european uh
radio you could face five years jail
time that's why
they're de-platforming christians
they're deplatforming
anyone that opposes them and brings
forth the truth
because they're terrified of the truth
like i always say lie
is afraid of the truth truth is never
afraid of the lie so they need to
remove people like me we are growing we
are growing by the thousands
our church is full we have thousands of
people coming to the rallies and then we
have become political prisoners there
are
starting to be afraid of us and my
message to you
is watch what's happening here because
it's coming your way
unless you rise up and stand up and
fight you have to be like
lions chasing off the hyenas
oh pastor pavlovsky you're also polish
so i just love you for that reason okay
i was like i'm half polish you're polish
so you got that fight in you the polls
always do
uh pastor thank you great to see you
tonight and good luck
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else